thank you very much maurice yes i'm here
with anish giri one of the most
entertaining uh players on
the roster here in romania anish first
of all take us through the game
it seemed at some point that you were on
top
yeah the opening went well for you tell
us a little bit more about it another
one as he confessed this through 88 was
a
was a horrible horrible move in general
the way you want to position your rooks
usually is the you want to bring this
rook so let's say here
this rook let's say here i mean just for
argument's sake and then
you want to perhaps put the bishop here
so this is how you want to play it and
then the bishop sort of
can come out to c6 the rooks are putting
pressure on the c pawn and everything's
sort of harmonious
uh after d8 bishop c8 is really not the
case now this
is out if you try to do it the other way
around yeah but it really doesn't work
now because the ruben effect is now
passive there's nobody putting pressure
on c4 pawn the bishop is far from c6
so the this whole plane of rookdate
bishop c8 i mean here i realize he's in
deep trouble and i was thinking maybe
he should somehow try to bring the rook
back to c8 you know and then this rook
to d8 after all and now i was thinking
what about these positions you know
these typical positions uh now i have
extra move a4 but it's not so
um not so clear how much it benefits me
but basically
yeah druid and bishop 8 was a disastrous
plan and i reacted well for a while and
here i'm having a dominant position
already first of all i'm not sure if i
should trade but i thought it was
good enough of course you won't might
want to keep more pawns because
sometimes always maybe a6
yeah but well i i thought what i did was
very very strong i thought he has to
at some point go i was considering
knight c5 and then it's very very
unpleasant for him he will lose the c5
pawn
in a bad version and uh i started
missing most bishop f6 i still saw but
then
bishop before that was very strong i
thought i have him now where i want to
have him i thought he doesn't have a
move
and i calculated 95 where i trade
everything and then i force his rook to
to be passive and i pick up the pawn
nicely but g5 was very strong this
bishop is completely live
yeah the bishop said jiva was very very
accurate now um
at first i thought it's not a big deal i
was just playing to go f3 king g7
perhaps king of two but then i realized
that he's going down knight c5
and now at the end of this line where i
do what i was usually sort of doing i'm
going to win
his king gets in uh not only it's not so
much the king it's more that
um let's say here it's more that now he
has the pawn on g5
and now he's going to drop the rook to
d1 and he has the through h1 counter
play and let's say with pawn g7 i would
have h4 and i have my pawn
but in general yes i'm lacking space my
bishop is
now out of play he lost the pawn but now
he turned around the coordination and i
think
h1 is coming i think it's just a draw on
the spot at least and basically anytime
you try to exchange the bishop he'll
happily do that yeah but like yeah
it's so so slow and rugged one is
already next moving
e1 is there so i thought okay if
tricking you know king f2 is not not the
right way so let me think what the right
way is and then i kept thinking and
thinking
and i realized that okay it's strange
but maybe it's already nothing
and with that in um yeah then f4 of
course of course that f4 is not great
because
i mean i had some idea that here i would
go
e3 perhaps and go bishop d4ed or um
but already a position like that to
train change the pawn structure maybe
keep
some chances against the b6 pawn but
already clearly in general i understood
of course
when you do move like a four you give
him counter play with e5 and he played
e5 very accurately
and then knight g4 and then also yeah
bishop 6 is the most accurate movement
now it's forced with that in mind i made
mistake earlier than i th
well i mean i made a mistake here
obviously of course this position is
overwhelming
and as no one pointed out bishop e3 was
very very strong
maybe at some point could you have
played h4 to stop him from going g5
maybe i'm not sure if h4 is it
yeah there you take take bishop c6 um
yeah but the problem is that uh
maybe it's anyway better moved in the
game but i thought that he might want to
take
take and maybe 95 or something like that
so uh that was my
idea and uh yeah i didn't really think
i mean also i'm not sure if i even saw
that like i'm not winning a piece or
something you know
like i'm not i'm not getting a piece
because you should send me [ __ ] before
so i'm not sure if i saw g5 at all
i definitely underestimated it and i
thought if he makes a loft
for the king it was going to be h6 or
something so g5 was very useful because
later down the line you saw that rook h1
the h2 pawn is going to be weak
in general it's very often in games the
g5 is a good move so i should have seen
it coming and of course
yeah in hindsight it just doesn't feel
likely because that bish pawn f6 seems
to be hanging in some uh yeah as well
and i mean the thing is that i thought
that my advantage is overwhelming that
uh
um you know it's not enough to make one
move it's gonna go away so i thought
yeah
but of course i i realized that i should
play precise i just thought bishop v6
was that nice move i like to reload in
the bishop to b5
keep that c4 pawn under control but
bishop p3 was very very strong now
knight c5 i see even and now i can first
of all sorry i can also uh
take in fact everything as i wanted but
for that i wanted the bishop on c6 so i
have king 2 there
but also i see rook db1 yeah it's very
very
very good looks kind of winning for me
and
yeah i should have he seen it he saw
this move so i should have seen it uh
as well but especially peter because the
way he handled the opening i had just an
enormous chance and
position is so easy to play yeah you you
talked a little bit in the first round
about
taking risk and trying to quantify how
much risk you can take
after yesterday's accident how much risk
were you
going to take today yeah not much
though i have to say you know
very often it looks like somebody's
taking a risk um
for example you might think that some
might go bishop g5 knight or if you know
maybe that's well maybe that's risky
but then the idea is that everybody both
players know that you know it's the
first line and in fact you are just
testing your opponent's memory
um in this uh day and age this
is sort of uh the you know it's slightly
changed a little bit the with the people
knowing so much theory
uh the definition of risk is sort of
changing uh to an extent i mean
there are no more uh risky lines that
nobody has studied i mean
trumpowski everybody knows 1v3 people
also know uh
what they're supposed to do so um and if
you play king's gambit i mean
well it is a risk but it's like an
insane risk because everybody is sort of
supposed to have that covered as well
especially with magnus playing in all
these rapid tournaments on stop
he also playing b3 before everybody's
preparing all these moves against him
now so
um you know even if you want to take the
risk it's very hard
so i mean i think it's just in my case
today i just tried to
and i had a small idea of course it's
one of the least risky ones
but i would rather have uh
an idea in some other line where his
king is in big danger and he has to make
10 only moves
to defend from checkmate but i couldn't
find such position in his refresher so i
had to
have to make my little movie for well
speaking of uh risky openings and uh
this is just a personal question how did
you come up to do
a uh dragon chestable course and talk a
little bit about that
what did you find give us something um i
can tell you
the so we were preparing it for the
candidates tournament and we were
looking at all sorts of because i had to
win against one e4
uh well try to win i guess 24 because i
was facing yan and
nvl as well and so we looked at all
sorts of ridiculous options
and dragon was one of them but it turned
out that the dragon actually
actually is okay for black um it's a
question of course
how much winning chances it actually
offers against top player so
uh i didn't play that finally but it is
very sound and then um
well apparently i didn't really expect
that but um we couldn't
refute it so i thought you know probably
i'm not going to play it not because it
doesn't work but just because maybe some
other things give me more uh chances
against those particular opponents
but such great knowledge cannot go to
waste so i decided to make adjustable
course instead and
i shared their this idea in the main
line and
i looked a lot at the sidelines and i
think it was very useful because you
know you got this
dragon structures also in openings that
i play like the night or
and i think it should help um with my
understanding
of there as well because uh like dragon
is not just an opening it's a pawn
structure
like for example you've got the benoni
yeah it's a it's an opening but it's
also a pawn structure you've got like
the stone wall
it's an opening but it also can arise
from catalan so you've got these opening
slash pawn structures and uh
i think uh studying the dragon sort of i
thought it would be useful for me but in
terms of like playing
the actual dragon um i'm not sure
uh i myself will do that hopefully my
students will because nothing nothing
wrong with the dragon
as a former dragon player that got
checked made it way too many times i
commend you for that
so yeah but there's like not even
there's not even close like the lines
i'm recommending there's no checkmate
uh the main battlefields are some
theoretically speaking some end games
where black is
uh accurately holding and yeah we're
diverging the attack there's no
there's no checkmates in the dragon in
2021. there you have it guys
dragon is safe back in the studio